bonjour messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions comment est-ce que vous
accueillez les annonces ce matin du
ministère de la santé comme quoi il
faudra être vaccinés pour pouvoir être
remboursés d'un test pcr ou antigénique
je sais pas si c'est moi qui commence
bonjour a tous écouté en là la chance
d'être en france d'avoir un système de
santé très protecteur
mais il ya un moment où il faut que ce
soit cohérent et juste c'est à dire si
tout le monde joue le jeu dans l'intérêt
général c'est bien aussi que certains
prennent conscience de se faire vacciner
est importante pour les autres moi je me
suis fait vacciner pas pour moi pour les
autres en plus tout est pris en charge
dans un pays alors dans certains pays
les tests sont jusqu'à 150 voire 160
euros et même des fois plus cher il ya
un moment donné il faut vraiment qu'on
ait cette conscience de cette chance
d'avoir ce système de santé protecteur
dans notre pays
j'enlève face à rien votre avis oui je
pense qu'au delà on était au fond de
tous ces mesures allaient finir par la
crise allait devenir une réalité dans
les prochains jours je pense qu'il faut
pas confondre aujourd'hui finalement une
opinion qui soit pro bac sans procès
n'était avec un blanc seing donné au
gouvernement sur les questions de
vaccination de lutte contre la crise
sanitaire je pense qu'il ya des choses
qui ont été faits qu'on me le discrédit
jeté le discrédit mine de rien sur la
parole scientifique et sur la plan
gouvernemental qui font aujourd'hui on
en est à 13 ou 14 samedi de mobilisation
et que finalement on a une défiance un
peu généralisée envers le gouvernement
mais aussi envers la communauté
scientifique alors est ce qu on doit
passer uniquement par du répressif ou
pas d'invitation de liberté avec le pass
sanitaires ou avec le bateau le
non-remboursement des tests moi je ne
pense pas je pense qu'il ya une logique
de dialogue à remettre en place et une
logique d'explication une logique de
pédagogique à mettre en place notamment
sur les traitements ou on doit aussi
expliquer pourquoi ce qui peut marcher
ce qui ne peut pas marcher et quel est
l'intérêt du vaccin avec une démarche
pédagogique et pas forcément tous dans
un schéma
finalement un peu coercitif qu'on est en
train de voir aujourd'hui avec les
actions gouvernementales
messieurs 13e samedi mobilisation anti
passe sanitaire selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur plus de 47 wind
français étaient dans les rues de
l'hexagone le week-end dernier je me
retournais vous nouveau vers vous jean
le pas sérieux puisque vous êtes contre
le pass sanitaires
selon vous combien de personnes dans les
rues aujourd'hui
non non nous nous on n'est pas content
le passé à lutter avec les jeunes ont
des formes plutôt aussi le le passé ni
terre là la différence aujourd'hui entre
nous et le l'action gouvernementale
c'est pas d'être contre où le procès
n'était à ses yeux d'avoir une opinion
finalement un peu entre les deux d'abord
une opinion juste sur ces questions-là
devient ne pas dire nous on passe à un
hyper de défendre le passé à necker mais
de ne pas défendre le passé la seule
chose comme comme comme information a
donné aujourd'hui à nos concitoyens
l'information donnée si l'information
une information qui est limitatif de
liberté c'est d'aller vers un discours
scientifique qui est venu nous expliquer
qui est mieux dit est aujourd'hui
passée par le gouvernement c'est logique
qu'il ya une méfiance à peu généralisés
sur ces questions là et c'est ce que
nous regrettons aujourd'hui
est ce que vous pensez riber l'évêque
cette défiance dont parle jean louis pas
sérieux va s'exprimer à nouveau
aujourd'hui dans la rue quarante sept
mille personnes la semaine dernière
est-ce qu'il va y avoir encore du monde
selon vous
écoutez ces principes en france de
donner une importance à une minorité à
boyaux qui fait du bruit mais la
majorité silencieuse qui représente la
plus grande majorité des français ça
représente même pas 1% de français donc
voilà c'est bien qu'ils s'expriment qui
disent qu'ils ont à faire on a eu les
gilet jaune maintenant là les antilles
passe mais je veux dire voilà c'est le
samedi après midi c'est devenu une
habitude pour certains de sortir de
retrouver leurs collègues ils
s'expriment ça met de l'animation mais
en même temps la majorité des français
sont pour se passe parce que les ont une
esprit solidaire un esprit collégial
parce qu'on vit les uns avec les autres
et on doit avoir des règles collectives
pour se protéger les uns les autres
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça après
effectivement sur la forme sur le fond
sur le fond il n'y a pas de souci mais
sur la forme il ya des ajustements
évidemment à faire mais l'intérêt
général prime avant tout l'intérêt
général c'est tout on l'a vu jean lui
pas sérieux de samedi en samedi les les
revendications quelque peu changé des
personnes qui se mobilisent dans les
rues initialement donc contre le pass
sanitaires et l'obligation vaccinale
d'aidés soignants
il ya des gilet jaune qui vont
participer aujourd'hui à des cortèges
est ce qu'il y à son bout d'une
convergence des luttes ans et ya la
présidentielle qui approche à grands pas
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce losc une
convergence des luttes elle est légitime
en tout cas je pense que plus
généralement au delà des au delà des
questions purement sanitaire automne
chaud analyse un peu plus politique je
pense qu'effectivement il ya une
défiance généralisée questions
sanitaires et économiques ou politiques
et le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une porosité parfois entre certaines
revendications et peut y avoir un espèce
de mélange assez assez
forcément peu précis mais il ya vraiment
un besoin de clarté en tout cas dans la
danse dans la parole publique sur ces
questions là et il ya aussi besoin de
peut-être une d'une évocation
démocratique sur les questions même
sanitaires jeudi la perspective de
donner aussi la parole au peuple sur ces
questions sanitaires et c est peu
importante aujourd'hui aujourd'hui au
lieu des crêtets impasse sanitaire
unilatéralement cdc tout ça fait des
choses comme beaucoup d'autres dans
notre société qui peuvent faire aussi
l'objet de référendum ou de ce type
d'outil qui peuvent leur être une
acceptation sociale beaucoup plus
importante je pense que l'âme est la
démocratie un peu plus direct pas
forcément on est pas
démocratie complètement direct vraiment
une solution pour une acceptation
sociale de mesure en effet rejoindre mon
interlocuteur qui sont plutôt d'intérêt
général mais qui sont parfois mal
expliqué ou parfois qu'ils sont vécus
comme unilatéralement imposé finalement
alors que avec un + démocratie une
parole scientifique un peu plus calme et
un peu plus sereine sur le sujet on
arrivera peut être à une meilleure
acceptation sociale de ces questions
eric vers l'hiver votre réaction sachez
qu'il ya eu une manifestation encore
mais pas contre le pass annie terre
c'était plus des questions sociales 1
mardi dernier on l'a vu samedi dernier
avec des motifs des revendications
sociales et également est-ce qu en fait
peut-être que la mobilisation contre le
pass sanitaire
est en train de changer 2
d'aspect
forcément ça va évoluer on est à six
mois des élections présidentielles on
est dans un pays des droits et des
devoirs où on a plus tendance ces
derniers temps à utiliser les droits et
oublier les devoirs est effectivement
l'avantagent de ces manifestations ça
amène la réflexion ça amène le débat ça
mène les échanges encore faut-il qu'elle
soit construite et qu'elle apporte à
chacun il faut pas qu'ils aient une
manipulation de certains réseaux de c2c
de ces manifestations est plutôt que les
politiques ou les acteurs ceux qui
veulent s'emparer de ces débats apporte
des solutions des propositions la
période est propice à ça on est à six
mois des élections présidentielles
chacun doit apporter sur la table des
idées des propositions et qu'on ait une
convergence collective on est dans un
beau pays républicain où il ya une
multitude de tendance et c'est le moment
justement de deschamps j'ai discuté de
faire des rapports qui peuvent amener à
la réflexion collective donc c'est ça
l'intérêt la rue est la base de la
réflexion donc moi je vais pas les
pointer du doigt juste qu'il ya respect
et qu' il faut relativiser les choses
entre c'est toute petite minorité qui
dans la rue avec cette grande majorité
silencieuse qui en navarre de beaucoup
de choses aussi et qui s'exprime dans
les yeux et qui s'expriment l'objectif
des élus c'est que le plus de monde
possible qui s'exprime dans les urnes
puisque le plus grand élu et
l'abstentionniste donc il faut faire
attention à ça mais moi je j'apprécie
les manifestations dans les rues parce
que c'est important c'est l'embryon de
la réflexion et du développement de des
changes et à quel type de rendez-vous
vous attend dès cet après midi
là je ne sais pas qui on va s'attendre
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que il y aura toujours une minorité qui
fera n'importe quoi et d'autres qui
auront tendance à récupérer l'événement
politiquement on revient que florian
philippot et d'autres personnes essaye
d'exister politiquement et veulent
récupérer un mouvement très populaire
alors fins personnelles donc il faut
raison garder et puis bien équilibrer
les choses mais on voit très bien que ce
mouvement ça peut pas toujours la même
population et les mêmes personnes qui
sont dans la rue et et on attend des
propositions des idées et pas des idées
de consommateurs des idées d'acteurs de
notre public sénat récupération son
métier que selon vous jean-luc pas
sérieux c'est ça alors moi j'ai pas
forcément parler d'eux les autres
récupération politique mais je pense que
en tout cas les élections
présidentielles qui s'approche ça sera
aussi le moment de juger l'action
gouvernementale sur la crise anitea ça
va être surtout demande par exemple de
parler des questions de citoyenneté qui
sont chères dans notre dans notre
mouvement aujourd'hui on pourra pas
faire l'économie d'un débat sérieux
d'une critique sérieuse de l'action
gouvernementale durant les derniers mois
durant cette crise sanitaire on
n'oubliera pas les problèmes de masque
on n'oubliera pas le nom présente un
vaccin français on n'oubliera pas ce
genre de choses on n'oubliera pas que
l'on ne met plus en plus dépendants de
l'inde de la chine pour damon des mets
des molécules qui chie soigne on
n'oubliera pas qu'on a dû donner des
masses de décathlon ou donner des sacs
poubelles d'avoir des bourses pour nos
infirmières on n'oubliera pas tout ça
alors évidemment moi moi le message
c'est pas bête anti passe aujourd'hui
que je veux donner c'est réfléchissons à
comment pour cette pandémie et pourrait
potentiellement les prochaines comment
assurer une souveraineté vraiment avec
le made in france avec ce genre de
choses comment avoir une véritable
souveraineté pour pouvoir mieux gérer
les pandémies caries avec aussi un
agenda démocratique qui sera plus
important pour une meilleure acceptation
sociale et je pense que ces deux
questions au delà de la récupération
politique elles doivent être centrale
dans les débats pour la présidentielle
de 2000 m2 merci messieurs d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci jean louis
pas sérieux d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
membre des jeunes avec arnaud montebourg
d'ailleurs vous avez aimé la marinière
merci également à vous eric berlivet
maire de la ville de roche là molière et
membre du mouvement générations terrain